what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
shooters inside my crib by quavo
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell that we are going to be notified of
my daily videos just so you guys know if
you have watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe me
you we have what beef
beef we are beefing yup
okay
on top of that follow my instagram just
dot pearly things just dot pearly things
my name is pearl just dot pearly thanks
[Music]
look at this food they trying to make me
hungry i could eat i could i can out oh
i can eat
[Music]
i was patient
how much do you think that chain is
worth okay i talk about this every video
why
do you wear expensive jewelry that's
like saying rob me rob me please
that looks expensive like and my second
question is is that heavy the jewelry
like
i would think
that it would like affect your posture
in some way
go see a chiropractor sir
glacier
i was trapping out the vacant until i
got some people yeah i wasn't looking
for the smoke and then i got some strain
i was like i was looking for the smoke
and then i got some strainer
so if i was looking for some smoke does
this mean i was looking for some drama i
think i'm looking for some drama let me
keep going
some drinks cause they thought i could
make it
i put that on my soul no you
i'm sorry i gotta pause every two
seconds because you all keep
copyrighting me and i'm making no money
it's very frustrating but i'm bopping
i'm bopping i'm like this is a big
shimmy you know the arms up
vacation
[Music]
party beach locations yeah
so he said we switch locations that
means he likes to move around a lot
mama said don't make no sense cause i
got shooters in all my cribs
okay mama said i don't make no sense
because i got shooters inside my crib so
he's saying that people want to come
after him
he's a wanted guy and it's weird because
like this is apparently kind of like a
good thing like it's cool
to have people after you it means like
you're almost on the top because you're
a target
now personally i don't think that's cool
if someone said i got shooters like
after
me i would say i need to find a new
friend because i will not be caught in
the crossfire let me tell you that i
don't know who it's gonna be
it's not gonna be me
nope i'm a fraidy cat and i'd take my
freighty cat ass out of there or maybe
saying his friends are the shooters that
could be another thing which let's say
they are again i don't want to be
friends with people that are shooters
y'all are shooting people
i'ma take my freighty cat ass
back to my friday cat family
where we live
on a friday cat piece of land in the
frady cat middle of nowhere soon enough
to deal with anyone the only thing we
shoot is deer okay
it's kind of hard to be a young [ __ ]
when you gotta watch the way that you
live
[Music]
it's never too hard to keep it real keep
it 100 we on and off of the field
okay so he's saying he keeps it real
he he he's a truth teller he's always
going to tell you the truth
[Music]
if he caught a body he signed a deal
so caught a body that means to shoot
someone then he signed a deal with the
police
i know i'm already on i'm on my game
today
upgrade to watch it from stainless steel
if you woke up in the morning and got
you a million just tell me just how
would you feel gave my [ __ ] some points
so mention percentage just look at the
way that they live whoa
wait do you see all those records he
must be good quavo
cueva oh my gosh that's cardi b's
husband i know who that is he was in the
migos thing i know okay
glacier i was trapping out the vacant
until i got some paper
i was looking for the smoke and then i
got some strain
what is this strainer i was looking for
the smoke and then i got some strainer
you are trying to make me hungry sir
that looks so good i was out there
chasing drinks because they thought i
could make it
i put that on my soul no you can't take
it
okay on the highway we're going to
places prison or vacation i pick
vacation vacation that's what i pick
let's not go to prison vacation
only vacation that's
[Music]
so the reason i'm gonna tell you guys
the reason he's showing he showed the
crowds he showed his record deals now
he's showing his big chains and cash
he's saying
i am successful that's the message he's
trying to show off in the movie i'm cool
i'm successful
look at me
mama said don't make no sense cause i
got shooters in
back to the shooters in the cribs
i won't be at your crib sir
[Music]
and also smoking's bad for you oh my
gosh the video's over
i really liked that song i'm surprised
i'm really not a big rap music person
but lately i've been giving these songs
a lot higher ratings than i thought so
i'm gonna give that one a five
out of five so that's that's a ten
if you can do math so
okay guys
leave a comment let me know what you
would rate the song one to five
and let me know what song i should react
to next in the comments
and if you're seeing this and you own
the rights to the song please don't
copyright me please
please i'm so tired of getting all these
views and making no money please don't
do it please okay
also subscribe i'll talk to you guys
next time